Britain's Prime Minister Theresa May is
meeting with national security advisors
this morning to discuss a poisoning of a
Russian double agent in southern England
officials are urging about 500 people to
take safety precautions after church's
traces rather of nerve agent were found
in two different locations
Sergey scree pol and his daughter are
still in critical condition today
following the March fourth attack
Charlie d'Agata is in Salisbury where
residents concerns are growing Charlie
good morning well good morning to you
there is the Italian restaurant still
barricaded off and with good reason
considering that warning we're told at
the table that they were sitting out was
actually taken away and destroyed they
were found not far from here slumped
over a park bench fighting for their
lives more military personnel and hazmat
suits descended on Salisbury over the
weekend removing potentially
contaminated vehicles and cordoning off
the graves of Russian spies Sergey
scruples wife and son as it turns out
traces of a suspected nerve agent were
found in an Italian restaurant and a
nearby bar prompting a warning for the
customers who may have visited wash
clothing you haven't already ideally in
the washing machine any items which
cannot be washed and would normally be
dry-cleaned should be double bagged in
plastic until further information is
available more than a week after the
suspected poisoning inscri pol and his
daughter julia people wonder why it took
so long to issue that kind of warning I
think it's a little too late I think
there should have been more information
quicker and while investigators say
they've identified the nerve agent used
in the attack they have not made that
information public or named a possible
suspect in 2006 another Russian
intelligence officer Alexander
Litvinenko was murdered in London after
he was poisoned by radioactive polonium
British intelligence believed that was a
Russian state ordered execution at the
time Theresa May told his widow marina
that she would do anything to stop a
similar incident from happening again
it means something was not done and a
lesson what we received after murder of
my husband
was not learned now even before this
morning's meeting of the National
Security Council the head of the Foreign
Affairs Committee here said this
poisoning looks like state-sponsored
attempted murder Nora
Laurie Charlie thank you so much